it goes on the floor and then it spins
it what my yogurt in the break room
Oh Marga I gotta call you back might to
catch me a case yo let's go okay I'm
gonna go you know eat a man's your your
that's all I can eat no I think he's
gonna wrinkle go fight okay who's
fighting is someone fighting
fight fight fight fight fight you can't
be snacking on my snacks like that give
me the news of the dick break it but
Polly go along no is never another
man laughs gorgeous we did it Oh watch
it dude what the hell is going on in
here
listen lady why don't you just why don't
I apologize to everyone in this room for
what I just did totally uncalled for
I'm sorry everyone sure great what are
you he's my cousin
of course he is sister Aharon I figured
he'd be a great member of the sales team
right unless he's a local hero so he
sure is jumped in front of a firetruck
saved the little girl's life miss I
promise you I will give you my best and
I will deliver all right whatever but
you three are responsible for training
him and if he doesn't deliver it's on
you what are you looking at come on
let's go sorry man to me yes oh dude we
just got you a job jeez man
you